you manage
at least in my estimation to stay
productive i think you're extremely
productive
you might not consider yourself to be
some people think i'm counter-productive
well either way there's a word
productive in there
you're doing something do you do you
consider yourself to be productive and
do you take nootropics
what does your schedule look like how do
you maintain this
i have no schedule um
i have a terrible sleep schedule i don't
uh take no tropics i i don't
self-optimize in any of the sort of tim
ferriss style
ways um why not
well it's a very weird question there
are ways in which i think
like i really left this planet when i
started
taking theoretical physics very
seriously and i don't
exactly know what those words mean but
it's a sort of a dissociative brain
state where you don't really think about
this as the plane of existence you think
about trying to commune with something
else
it means you sort of lose track of the
here and the now the practical
the instance of something you know if i
have a coffee mug
do i see this as the platonic essence of
all coffee mugs or do i see it as the
particular coffee mug that i'm holding
that has a chip on one side you know
i think that i started to move towards
greater and greater abstraction
how i interacted with the world and
probably caused me not to focus too much
on the sort of west coast
optimization program
in part i also think that a lot of those
people spend so much time
optimizing themselves that they don't do
anything with the optimized machine that
they create
and so there is a trade-off and
for better for worse i decided to
ignore some aspects of that to
pursue something that seemed impossible
so it's like they're constantly
defragmenting and they're not running
any applications or
besides the disk optimization i didn't
say that but that's quite funny